we want to take a look back way back at
an appearance you had on the simple life
because fans have been begging
for a reboot oh that's when i had orange
here
hi sexy his name is rob are you a cowboy
no i'm an investment banker actually
would you like to dance
so if this was your mom though i'm gonna
vomit
[Applause]
thank you for embarrassing me
let's talk about your podcast kesha and
the creepies i was so excited to hear
that you were doing this because i'm
really into
spiritual things and like the
supernatural and i'm just like
i would call myself a spiritual
explorer and i'm doing on my podcast is
i'm just talking about anything
supernatural
anything unexplainable i'm talking to
musicians about the craziest stuff
they've ever gone through
all different kinds of people from all
over the world and
getting their wildest experiences and
it's just like helping my perspective
grow
just seeing world and spirituality and
the supernatural from everybody's
different perspectives has been so
interesting for me what's so cool about
this podcast though is that you are
talking to other people other pop
culture figures other celebrities about
these stories and there's just such a
genuine conversation there
um like it's so easy to listen to what
would you say is like the
coolest or biggest thing you learn from
these conversations
with demi lovato i loved the
conversation we had
because she just turned me on to like
a whole new there are a couple books she
mentioned and an app she mentioned that
i
immediately downloaded and i made my
family for christmas all i want for
christmas is
us all to meditate and try to channel
extraterrestrials and they're like okay
so i'm like
trying to get all my friends and family
into
meditating the aliens to us
my new hobby because of daniel obama
summoning that thank you demi for that
uh you know obviously your your hardcore
fans know that you've always kind of
been in tune i mean it's even
in your music right uh talking about the
supernatural what do you hope we learn
about you
in this podcast you know i think that
during quarantine i had a really
bizarre experience that i
just was having a lot of anxiety
i've never been distilled the world
has just been at war this past 12 months
like
the energy is just really insane and
we're facing things that
need to be faced and need to be
addressed but going through
this hasn't been i think probably an
easy experience it's necessary
but it's just been like a lot of anxiety
and i hope people can tune in and just
like i'm in this place where i just want
to grow i want to
see things from different perspectives i
want to understand and i want to
find empathy for people i don't want to
fight i don't
i just want to understand people so tune
in and it's fun and we both
about crazy poor experiences with alice
cooper but then we also talked about you
know our
own spirituality between me and
so many different kinds of people and
i'm speaking to a wizard
at the beginning of february you're
gonna hear it when i talk to a wizard
like the real wizard who made
unicorns in the 80s come on come on
come on in that sense has it been
helpful for you in your life especially
during this time to kind of like
refocus the energy into something like
this podcast
yes i love making music and i
love my fans but i also feel like on my
spiritual
and personal growth side i want to take
them with me on
that journey because it's been really
influencing the music i'm making
and i want to be as connected to
everyone
and grow as much as humanly possible
because they think it's necessary we
need to grow
we need to grow and grow together and i
just want to find
common ground and just have
conversations with people
i think it's fighting and yelling i feel
like conversations
be a nicer way to deal with for sure
you want to relate to people on a human
level not as
musicians not as artists not as
celebrities but as humans i get that
well and not
as like a democrat or a republican right
i just want to talk to people because i
think if we all kind of
put our egos aside we're all human
beings and i think
hey if you actually speak to people you
can just understand them
more we want to take a look back way
back at an appearance you had on the
simple life because fans have been
begging
for a reboot oh that's what i had warren
here hi sexy his name is rob are you a
cowboy
no i'm an investment banker actually do
you like to dance
so if this was your mom though i'm gonna
vomit
thank you for embarrassing me
like do you even know and remember that
kesha that version
oh yeah that was like i remember when
they came to stay at my mom's house that
she still lives in that house and i
remember they ended up hooking her up
with a guy
on that show that a week later i went
out to
the gay bar and i saw him like out
dancing and i was like you went on a
date with my
mom and he was like yeah that is some
tea
i am so shook over that that's hilarious
i can't believe that well fans are
asking for a reboot of the simple life
would you like to see it come back
if they want it i don't know if i
can export that um that look
at foreign i don't think that looks ever
going to be what i revisit
that that looks taunts me that it lives
on the internet but we should do a
simple life with you
the lead i i feel like
i don't even know what that means what
do you do you roam around and uh
work at different kinds of jobs i think
they would just put you in experiences
you've never been in
you know what i mean in cities you've
never been in
no no that's true you have done it all
on that note i mean
music a cosmetics line your podcast
what's left on the kesha bucket list
i mean
i don't know that's a good question i
like i have a couple things
that i like want to do i really want to
become a scuba dive instructor one day
i'm obsessed with animals and like i
have like a bunch of whale tattoos and
stuff so i'm like
really obsessed with animals and just
spending as much time as possible with
animals so
anything that can get me in the water
with an animal and game for